¿Podríais decirme qué haríais con 250
billones de dólares?
Billones en español, ¿eh?. Estoy seguro de que os vienen un montón de caprichos a la cabeza.
Efectivamente es una cantidad tan grande
de dinero que vamos, hay años que ni
siquiera Bill Gates los gana, pero si
ahora os digo que esos 250 Billones de
dólares son dólares de Zimbabue la
cosa cambia y mucho.
Por 250 billones de
dólares de zimbabwe en 2015 te daban,
estad atentos, un dólar estadounidense.
¡Tal cual como lo oís! Lo cierto es que
Zimbabue es como Venezuela pero a escala
nachovidaliana,  es el país del mundo
que ha sufrido la inflación más
salvaje de la historia. Desde más o
menos el año 2000 los precios subían
cada año de forma disparatada.
Ya en el año 2008 una barra de pan
valía
ojo al dato 10.000 dólares zimbabuenses
Y os preguntaréis ¿cómo ha pasado esto?
Pues es muy sencillo.
Un día le llegó Robert Mugabe a su
ministro de finanzas y dijo oye mira a
ver cómo te las arreglas porque
necesitamos más dinero y que hizo el
bueno del ministro
pues lo mismo que haría el padre de
Neymar si le dejaran darle a la máquina
de imprimir billetes como si no hubiera
mañana. Conclusión, Zimbabue ha tenido
que renunciar a su propia moneda y ha
visto cómo las monedas extranjeras,
especialmente el dólar estadounidense,
dominaban su economía. Pero ¿Que está
pasando ahora en Zimbabue? En estas
últimas semanas de 2017
el país está siendo noticia porque ha
llegado el final de Robert Mugabe
Un golpe de estado donde las fuerzas
armadas han acabado con una dictadura de
37 años. Y mis queridos amigos de VisualPolitik hay que reconocer una cosa:
ni los golpes de estado son ya lo que eran.
Se puede decir que esto ha sido algo
así como un golpe de estado light,
especialmente cuando leemos noticias
como ésta
Robert Mugabe recibirá una
indemnización de 10 millones de
dólares e inmunidad para su familia".
Lo cierto es que este dictador se ha
visto envuelto en una trama propia de
telenovelas.
Mugabe con 93 años quería morir en el
poder y que su esposa Grace de 52 años
heredará la presidencia del país.
Cosas así solamente sucede en Argentina,
Corea del Norte o el Frente Nacional en
Francia. Y como os podéis imaginar
había muchísima gente que no estaba de
acuerdo,
así que ante cualquier gesto de
oposición a estos planes el clan Mugabe
mostraba al disidente de turno el camino
del aeropuerto de Hararé
Y esto fue, precisamente lo que pasó cuando a
principios de noviembre enviaron al
exilio al vicepresidente
Emmerson Mnangagwa. La reacción del
ejército no se hizo esperar y el
resultado ya lo sabéis pero ahora son
muchas las incógnitas que se ciernen
sobre Zimbabwe ¿Es Mnangagwa
el nuevo Mugabe? ¿Podrá resucitar la
economía de Zimbabue?
hoy vamos a responder a estas preguntas
pero antes vamos a ver un poco de Historia.
El efecto 2000
Efectivamente la
economía de zimbabwe es un auténtico
desastre y estaréis pensando: dictadura
y  África
suena como el cóctel perfecto para
tener corrupción y pobreza. Pues tenéis
razón pero solamente en parte. Hubo una
época en la que esto no era así
de hecho Zimbabue era conocida como la
joya de África.
Es más, sus tierras fértiles habían
convertido en el granero del continente
y os preguntaréis ¿qué pasó entonces
para qué un país con tantísimos
recursos agrícolas ,con recursos
naturales y con minas de oro y otros
metales haya pasado a ser un país en la
más absoluta ruina?
La respuesta tiene nombre y apellidos:
Robert Mugabe. 37 años hace de la
independencia de Zimbabue y 37 años ha
estado Mugabe en el poder.
La descolonización de la llamada a
Rhodesia del sur, que era una colonia
británica provocó una guerra civil
durante 15 años.
De un lado el gobierno de la minoría
blanca que suponía un 5 por ciento de
la población,
enfrentados además a sus superiores del
Reino Unido porque habían proclamado
unilateralmente la independencia y no
habían tenido el reconocimiento
internacional.
Del otro lado las fuerzas guerrilleras
comandadas por Robert Mugabe líder de
una ideología que combinaba el
nacionalismo antiimperialista con el
comunismo
Por aquel entonces, Margaret Thatcher era
la primera ministra del Reino Unido y ya
se lo que estáis pensando: guerra fría
más un gobierno comunista más Margaret
Thatcher no combinan precisamente bien
¿verdad? Pues os equivocáis por aquel
entonces el Reino Unido tenía como
prioridad dejar que sus antiguas
colonias se convirtieran en democracias,
así que la propia Margaret Thatcher
recién llegada a Downing Street
firmó un acuerdo de paz con Zimbabwe y
organizó unas elecciones en el país;
elecciones que fueron todos libres que
pueden ser cuando acabas de salir de una
guerra civil
y tienes a guerrilleros por todo el
país. Y ¿quién creéis que ganó estos
comicios? Efectivamente, Robert Mugabe
Y os preguntaréis ¿tiene credibilidad su
victoria? Pues todo indica a que sí.
Veréis, dentro de la población negra de
Zimbabue, que es la inmensa mayoría
frente al 5% que había de blancos,
predominan dos grupos étnicos
por un lado tenemos a los Shona que
representan un 80 por ciento de la
población; y por el otro
quedamos con este nombre los Matabele
que son solamente un 10 por ciento.
Pues bien, Robert Mugabe es de la etnia
de los Shona y por eso a nadie le
extrañó su amplia victoria en las
urnas con más de un 60 por ciento de
los votos.
Así que en 1980, Reino Unido concedió
entonces la independencia a Rhodesia que
pasó a llamarse Zimbabue y así es como
Mugabe comenzó a manejar este joven
país a su antojo. En sólo siete años
consiguió absorber todos los poderes
políticos en torno a su figura.
Pero... esperad  un momento porque hay que
reconocer que a nivel económico la cosa
funcionaba, al menos en los primeros
años. Mugaba respetó los derechos de
propiedad sobre la tierra, por lo que el
sector primario siguió tirando de la
economía.
Sin embargo y al más puro estilo de los
políticos venezolanos
Mugabe se gastó todo el dinero que
tenía ahorrado el anterior gobierno
colonial.
Por supuesto que aunque a largo plazo
sea bastante discutible y los números
no terminen de salir, hay que reconocerle
un logro a Robert Mugabe, Zimbabue logró
rápidamente la mayor tasa de
alfabetización del continente con
niveles próximos al 90 por ciento.
Y ¿qué es lo siguiente que hace un
dictador? Pues cargarse a la oposición,
lo cierto es que para eso Mugabe no
reparó en gastos. Envió a la quinta
brigada del ejército a Corea del Norte
para que aprendieran de sus métodos de
opresión política y cuando la quinta
brigada regreso a Zimbabwe les dijo
"id dónde están los Mataveles y
arrasad con todo". Y así es como en los
años 80
Mugabe ejecutó el llamado Gukurahundi
Gukurahundi significa en el idioma sonha
la lluvia que limpia la paja antes de
las lluvias de primavera.
Esta operación consistía en una
salvaje limpieza étnica un genocidio en
toda regla en el que más de 20 mil
personas de la etnia de los Matavele
fueron asesinadas. Y así es como Mugabe
logró mantenerse sin apenas oposición
política hasta el año 2000
En este año mugabe decidió poner en
marcha una reforma agraria
revolucionaria.
Nada volvió a ser como era y todo
cambió a peor
Mugabe decidió que no podía ser que
las mejores tierras fueran propiedad de
la minoría blanca,
así que se las arrebató por la fuerza.
¿Y quién recibió buena parte de esas
tierras?
Efectivamente los ministros y aliados
políticos de Mugabe que no tenían ni
idea ni recursos para trabajar la tierra.
Los resultados fueron tan
revolucionarios como la reforma, la
producción agraria cayó en picado
mientras la hiperinflación de la que ya
os he hablado disparaba los precios.
Desde entonces Zimbabue  vive un
auténtico apocalipsis económico.
La hora del cocodrilo
Dicen que los
cocodrilos esperan pacientemente bajo el
agua asomando sólo los ojos y las fosas
nasales hasta que una víctima incauta
se descuide y entonces atacan ferozmente
con sus mandíbulas. No, amigos
de VisualPolitik,
no queremos ser el nuevo National
Geographic sino simplemente explicaros
porque el nuevo presidente de Zimbabue
Emmerson Mnangagwa es conocido como el
cocodrilo.
Mnangagwa  fue uno más de los
líderes de la guerrilla de Mugabe y ha
sido ministro de Zimbabwe desde 1980,
así que ha estado toda la vida a la
sombra del dictador,
agazapado como un cocodrilo esperando su
momento.
Y ese momento ha llegado. Sus primeros
pasos han sido poco arriesgados tal y
como muestran noticias como está:
El gabinete del líder de Zimbabwe se
apoya en los militares y en el partido
gobernante.
Por eso, junto a estas medidas tan
conservadoras ha dado otros pasos un
poquito más arriesgados como éste:
"El gobierno enmienda la ley de indigenización".
La  ley de
indigenización es otra medida
económica de esas que son 100% Mugabe
style.
Esta consistió en que las empresas de
cierto tamaño no podían ser propiedad
de los blancos, y eso explica cómo os
podéis imaginar que la gente blanca
haya emigrado y ya sean menos de un 1
por ciento de la población. Pero rechazar
hacer negocios con alguien basándote
únicamente en su raza no parece la
mejor manera de atraer la inversión
internacional y Zimbabue necesita dinero
del extranjero.
Pero espera de un momento porque Mnangagwa podría no ser la persona más
adecuada para dirigir los designios del
país.
En un país como Zimbabwe encontrar
puntos negros en el historial de alguien
tan próximo a Mugabe es pan comido.
¿Qué hacía Mnangagwa  en los años 80? Pues
era el ministro de seguridad nacional
por lo que a la fuerza
algo tuvo que ver con el Gukurahundi.
Como podéis imaginar ser un genocida no
parece la mejor carta de presentación
para empezar a dirigir un país.
Y os preguntaréis ¿acaso no hay nadie
que haga una oposición firme a este
régimen?
Pues lo cierto es que sí, tal cual como
lo escucháis. En el año 2008 el dictador vio
cómo otro partido recibía más apoyo.
La crisis política fue enorme por un
lado Mugabe no podía atacar a un
opositor con tantísimo capital
político y apoyo social, por el otro
como el dictador no podía reconocerle
la victoria, así que Mugabe optó por
una decisión salomónica siguió
ostentando la Presidencia de la
república y cedió aa este líder
opositor que se llamaba Morgan Tsvangirai
los poderes de primer
ministro. Pero esperad un momento
porque esta confesión no fue más que
un espejismo y durante cuatro años este
líder opositor apenas tuvo margen de
actuación.
Sí, el país pudo crecer ligeramente
especialmente cuando adoptaron el dólar
estadounidense como moneda.
Pero... por lo
demás, los cambios fueron mínimos y
Zimbabue continuó dando noticias al
mundo como ésta:
Tasa de desempleo de Zimbabwe en el 90 por ciento.
Por eso Tsvangirai no parece ya una
alternativa al régimen.
Así que con el anuncio de elecciones
para el próximo año todo indica que el
camino está despejado para el cocodrilo.
El ejército va a tutelar los próximos
tiempos de Zimbabue con una ventaja
respecto a Mugabe: hacerlo peor en
economía es imposible.
Así que, ahora la
pregunta es ¿os parece que Mnangagwa será
capaz de hacer que Zimbabue vuelva a ser
la joya de áfrica o simplemente se
limitará a ocupar el trono de Mugabe?
Podéis dejar vuestras respuesta en los
comentarios.
Mientras tanto, si queréis conocer la
historia de otro país africano
en este vídeo os hablamos de egipto
hacer clic aquí para verlo y no
olvidéis que sacamos vídeos nuevos
todas las semanas así que suscribimos
al canal para no perderos ninguna de
nuestras actualizaciones. Si os ha gustado
este vídeo dadle a like y nos vemos en
el próximo.
un abrazo y hasta pronto